l'une des deux carcasses est encore sur
le parking de la copropriété
deux voitures ont été incendiées ici
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi les
habitants ont d'abord cru à un accident
l'incendié a été revendiquée par un
groupe anarchiste qui pensait s'en
prendre aux véhicules personnels du
député ce sont en fait les voitures de
ses voisins qui ont brûlé
je suis révolté je pense que nos
démocraties républicaines sont vraiment
en danger
ça a failli embraser l'immeuble d'autres
voitures c'est des gens n'avaient pas
réagi
bouleversé les pousses du député dénonce
une escalade de la violence à l'encontre
des élus c'est plus possible
je pense qu'à un moment donné je veux
lui dire écoute on arrête tout ça vaut
plus le coup de de donner sa vie parce
que finalement il a donné sa vie sa
famille tout ça pour le pour les autres
ce spécialiste des mouvements
anarchistes n'est pas surpris par l'
usage de la violence historique mais
marginal une tendance illégalistes
d'ailleurs condamné par la majorité des
libertaires lui a pas trop de
justification sais pas c'est pas un
fasciste n'y a pas trop virulent c'est
un personnage qui a une politique qui
est donc là sa manière respectable pour
le mouvement libertaire c'est pas du
tout pertinent quoi
si vous voulez les caricatures et les
renvoyer dans une position de bandits de
grand chemin ou de groupements dangereux
on n'aurait pas pu faire mieux donc sur
le plan là c'est c'est absolument
contre-productif
eric alauzet a été entendue à la mi
journée par les enquêteurs de la police
judiciaire
l'ensemble de la classe politique
bisontine lui a apporté son soutien